-Sean, thank you for being here.
How's everything with the show?
I'm very excited.
That's February 18th?
-February 18th, the game show,
and then "Hot Ones"
on First We Feast's YouTube
starts right back up next week.
-Next week.
-Margot Robbie for the premiere.
Yeah.
-Oh, my gosh. Alright, alright.
Here we go.
-Sean, I'm starving. Let's go.
-Thank you for doing this.
-Thanks so much for
having me, Jimmy.
Thanks for having me back.
J.J., it's an honor to have you
here in the hot seat.
And for those of you who are
wondering what the hell
is going on right here,
"Hot Ones" is simple.
We interview celebrities while
eating increasingly spicy
chicken wings,
and, as Jimmy can attest,
it gets very spicy very
quickly on "The Tonight Show."
We'll start in a mild zone
and work our way up to
the Last Dab XXX,
a sauce more than
250 times hotter than
a jalapeño.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The line is always hits
on live TV.
-It is all fun now.
Get ready, dude. It's insane.
-Alright.
-So, we'll start at the handle,
Los Calientes Rojo,
a turning-point sauce,
our halfway sauce.
-Okay. Alright.
-Here we go.
-Just eat the whole thing? Yeah?
-Up to you.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-Tasty.
-Yeah, not bad.
-Smoky.
-Delightful.
-Alright, J.J.,
my first question is for you.
-Okay.
-I know when you were a walk-on
at the University of Wisconsin,
to make ends meet, you were
a deliver driver for Pizza Hut.
What can you tell people about
that ill-fated day
where you were forced to eat
a customer's hot wings.
-This is true, actually.
So -- Sorry.
I was a pizza delivery driver,
and it was a snowy day
in Wisconsin.
They closed schools.
They closed businesses.
They closed everything.
Pizza Hut was
considering closing.
I told them,
"No, my parents have a truck."
So I can drive in the snow."
I came in, took an order out,
spun out into a mailbox,
wiped out a mailbox,
ended up in the front yard.
Called a tow truck.
A little spicy, not too spicy.
A little bit of spice.
-I was gonna say,
get into the story --
Yeah, yeah.
-So, I call a tow truck.
Tow truck spins out.
It's gone.
So I'm sitting in a car
with nothing to do
but two pizzas
and hot wings on the --
I ate the hot wings.
-Football players got to eat.
They got to eat.
You don't have to apologize
for that, J.J.
And as we move on here,
the good news is --
we're only going for four wings.
The bad news --
very steep ramp up.
-Okay.
-This is a Hot Thai Green
Hot Sauce.
-Thai green?
-Thai?
-Oh, man, this is kind of
ramping up, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-Jimmy on top of it.
I understand, Jimmy,
that you did not have
the most athletic childhood,
but it wasn't for
lack of trying.
I know it wasn't for
What can you tell us about
your dad installing
a basketball hoop
for you when were a kid?
-I got a basketball hoop
for Christmas from Santa Claus,
and my dad didn't want to
put it on the garage
because he thought the garage
would fall down.
And so he put it in
the middle of our backyard,
in the grass, in the lawn.
You can't dribble a ball
on grass.
And my dad was like, "Well, you
can just do foul shots."
And I go, "No.
No one is going to come over
and play with me,"
and so I hadn't had a
friend ever since.
-Moving -- You have a friend
in me, Jimmy.
-Thank you.
-You have two friends.
-Moving on.
Well, at least for now.
We'll see about
the friendship after this.
-Oh, no. This is not it.
-This is
Da Bomb Beyond Insanity,
a sauce we have to
apologize for.
-You have experience?
-So, J.J., in advance,
I say I'm sorry.
Jimmy, you know the drill
with this one.
-J.J., this is honestly
the turning point.
-It's only number three.
-No, this really -- This hurts
my feelings, this one.
This one insults me.
-I feel like it could hurt
something else, too,
the way you're talking about it.
-It's bad news. Alright.
-Alright, let's dig in.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Okay, yep.
-Immediate?
-Yep.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-It's almost like poison.
-Yeah, that's not pleasant.
The taste isn't even pleasant.
It's not pleasant.
-No.
-Very few redeeming qualities
with this one.
-No. I don't like it.
I don't like it.
-On the topic of J.J.
hosting "SNL" this weekend --
-Screw "SNL."
I mean, I...
I love "SNL." I'm hosting it.
You should probably --
Jesus, man!
-It's the sauce talking.
Jimmy, who do you think is
the funniest athlete
to ever host the show?
-Everyone, everyone.
-Dude...
-And what advice, if any,
do you have for J.J.?
-Read the cards.
-I need advice for this, Jimmy.
-Do the sketch.
-The air hurts.
-Well, then --
-Stop talking so loud.
-It is a good thing that we're
approaching the end of the line.
This is the Last Dab.
Let's make some noise
for Jimmy and J.J.
[ Cheers and applause ]
A heroic run.
We call it the Last Dab
because it is tradition
around here to put a
little extra on the last one.
You don't have to.
-You do what?
-You dab the last wing, but
you don't have to --
-With what? That?
-Yep.
-That's hotter than that?
Are you nuts?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Audience groans ]
Oh!
-Alright, yeah.
[ Groans ]
-Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They're getting on their feet,
and that means
that we have reached
the end of the gauntlet,
approaching the finish line,
and, Jimmy,
it's become a tradition
here on "The Tonight Show"
for us to play a little game.
And there is so much --
-Alright, what's the rules --
-Nope, I'm done!
-So much anticipation for
this weekend's Super Bowl
and, of course, the halftime
performance with
J.Lo and Shakira.
So, with your brain on fire,
tongue ablaze, mouth an inferno,
can you try to do
an impression --
-I don't want
to play any games, Sean!
-Can you do an impression of
a Super Bowl
performer from years past?
J.J., it's up to you to try
to guess the impression.
-Is this a prop?
-No, that's straight milk.
Go ahead.
-No, no.
-I won't, I won't, I won't,
I won't.
-If you drink milk --
-When you breathe, it hurts.
-Yeah. What was the question?
What was the question?
-An impression of a performer
from Super Bowls past.
-Okay.
-Who?
[ Singing indistinctly ]
-Mick Jagger!
-Yeah, yeah, perfect.
-Spot-on Mick Jagger.
Let's make some noise...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Water?
-...for Jimmy and J.J.
-Cheers, buddy.
-Cheers.
-Thanks to J.J. Watt
and Sean Evans.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys,
Season 11 of "Hot Ones"
next Thursday on YouTube.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break.
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪